let's get more on the developing racism
row after abuse was directed at england
players
on social media the chief secretary to
the treasury has today been forced to
defend the home secretary pretty patel
who was accused of stoking the fire in
her previous stance on the subject
three england players marcus rashford
jaden sancho and bakaya sacca were
subjected to abuse after missing spot
kicks
in the penalty shootout against italy
well let's speak now to labour mp
dawn butler hello to you dawn thanks
very much for being with us
we had two very powerful statements last
night
by tyrone mings and marcus rashford
do you feel that their voices are now
being heard
above the rest of the noise yes and i
think it's important that they speak out
i mean these footballers as well as
other black people in the public eye
receive racism before the game
during the game and now after the game
and this isn't a game to them in their
fight
to eradicate racism from their daily
lives
now this is the reason why they took the
knee and they made it
quite clear and unfortunately at
the top of our government the prime
minister and the home secretary
they decided not to support them
in that they decided to say that it was
just the politics and they wouldn't have
a part of it
yet still when they're on the winning
streak they they showed the
the biggest gesture politics that they
could ever buy themselves an english
shirt
and then say they're going to support
the team
you know and then to be surprised when
the players start receiving racist abuse
the very thing
why they were taking the knee shows
either a lack of
understanding complete hypocrisy
or just stupidity in a way
boris johnson spoke out yesterday to
condemn the abuse he told the racists to
crawl back under the
rock from which they had emerged we've
heard from the chief secretary to the
treasury today defending pretty patel
that she has
consistently taken a stand against
racism that it is something she has been
a victim of
herself she said there's no place in our
society that she backs the police
in holding those responsible accountable
what more do you want to see from the
government that's ridiculous i mean i'm
i'm completely happy that the government
is now calling out racism
but to say they've been doing this is is
doing
from the vacating is doing a lot of
heavy lifting this government has been
the most divisive government
government i've ever seen in my lifetime
they have stoked
a culture war deliberately they have
said that they were having this war on
woke
war and woke is about being considerate
to others that's what woke means and
this government has deliberately
gone on a path of stoking that
stoking hatred and stoking division in
our society
so to now say that they are um
that they are standing up against racism
i'm glad they're getting there everybody
has to go on a journey
but to pretend that they've been doing
this all along and they are not part of
the problem
you know that's not good enough people
are not stupid and that is the good
thing that i think
that has happened we've learned more
about people
and society because we've lost we've
learned more about
you know how people behave and how
people think and what
what gives me um optimism what makes me
optimistic
is the fact that there are far more
positive
anti-racists in society than there are
races it's just now people are now
seeing the races
for who they are but there are far more
people who are anti-racist and that
gives me hope
is not led by this government because
this government has done the complete
opposite
you know boris johnson gave a wink to
tommy robinson
when he said my people go and support
support him
so you know we take i'm glad they're
going on their journey
we've tried really hard in parliament to
bring them on this journey
so i'm glad they're now going on this
journey but they're not going to take
any credit for it i'm afraid
because they're part of the problem and
yet pretty patel has previously in the
past met
tyrone mings to discuss the issue of
racism
in football and at the time he said
she'd seen interested and engrossed
in the player's point of view so
that journey had already began had it
not
so sarah just imagine how disappointed
he would have felt
when they were taking the knee and she
said that it's just the politics just
imagine having a conversation with the
home secretary
and the home secretary saying i
understand i've been there i know what
racism feels like and then when you go
and do something about it when you take
action
you get no support from that person just
imagine how that felt
to them and that's what they're
highlighting you know you you will not
silence the voices
of these young men on the pitch you
won't silence the voices
of people who have been fighting racism
all of their lives
including myself and many others you
won't silence us in this fight because
society will be better
when we eradicate racism society will be
better when we call it out
and we eliminate it from all of the
systems and the structural racism
in society you know when we do that our
society
will be better yeah and as you say
you felt a sense of optimism uh
yesterday by uh the outpouring of
support the unity behind these players
who had experienced
racism how do we harness those voices
they are extremely influential
they have a platform and they are
speaking out
on a really important issue of which
they unfortunately
have far too much experience how do we
harness the power of that now
we keep listening and we keep giving
them a platform we don't shut them down
we don't pretend
it doesn't happen we don't dismiss that
it's happening we don't say it's part of
a woke brigade or we don't say
we need to give everybody a freedom of
speech it's not the same thing not
everybody
deserves that privilege and we keep
giving it a platform and we keep calling
it out and then we will see
the people that come out and say
actually i don't want to see that on my
football pitch i don't want to see that
on my social media platform you know two
years ago the government promised
an online harms bill we're still waiting
two years later
for this online harms bill the
government's been kicking this can down
the road
we know it's a problem but they don't
want to deal with it deliberately
because they think they can win
elections by stoking this division in
society
and having this cultural war and the
majority of us are saying oh no
no way not on our watch you know there
is one human race
so let's kind of work together let's
build a collaboration
you know let's say that we want a better
society you know
if you take the same people that abusing
people online are being racist
are the same people that are going home
and beating their partners
so you know we eradicate we call out
these people
we will rid society of many social ills
so it's not just a battle for one it's a
battle for all and a better society
yeah and um we do need to discuss the
role of social media companies don't we
giving a platform to these racist views
um in the last few minutes uh some
breaking news that the prime minister
is to meet social media companies in
downing street later to discuss
how better to tackle online abuse a
spokesperson for
boris johnson said the pm opened cabinet
by repeating his condemnation
of the racist abuse aimed at some of the
england team following sunday's euro
2020 final
he said the abuse was utterly
disgraceful and had emerged from the
dark spaces
of the internet he said he would use
today's meeting with social media firms
to reiterate the urgent need for action
ahead of tougher laws coming into force
through the online harms bill which you
were mentioning there
uh dawn butler and he added there is no
question this kind of abuse is extremely
upsetting unfair and needs to be
stamped out could this and i know we
have talked about this on multiple
occasions dawn butler
do you get the sense that this could be
a tipping point that finally that action
that has been called for for so long
might come no this is the prime minister
doing what the prime minister does
all the time you know he does that he
does jester politics he's doing
something that he thinks will put this
to bed
and it won't put it to bed because we've
had the online harms bill that's been
delayed for two years we've been calling
for this on the floor of the house
over and over again you know when we
call out the burning injustices what
does the government do
produce a race report that says racism
doesn't exist you know it's not just
what you say
it's what you do and it's how you treat
people you know the home
secretary has some draconian measures
and draconian laws
and the way she talks about migrants and
immigrants
is racist you know it's racist language
that's used to stoke division
so it's not just it's not just for this
moment we need to see real
action from this government but what i
really want to say i want to say
thank you thank you to everyone who
covered marcus rashford's
picture with warm messages and flowers
and
and like affirmations thank you to
everybody that's come out
and support the players thank you to
everybody who is an anti-racist
in society i want to say thank you
because it's by the power
of those people that is actually um
we're seeing movement
that we're seeing change and i think we
have to we have to be vigilant we have
to constantly be vigilant and we have to
constantly
call it out so thank you to everybody
that is in this
fight and that is being an anti-racist
because that's what makes a difference i
will not be looking to the prime
minister because i know he's track work
called
i know the language that he uses i know
how they talk in private and their
whatsapp groups we know what they're
about
we will constantly hold them to account
but at the end of the day
society matters and people matters and
being on anti-racist
matters so thank you to all the
anti-racists yeah and
and that question that that term
anti-racist what does it mean
to be an anti-racist what do people need
to do in order
to call this out it means that you have
to be
constantly vigilant it's not enough just
to not be racist or say
i don't say this word or that word or
you know i don't discriminate you have
to do more than that you have to call it
out whenever you see it
you have to stand up and say it's wrong
you have to call it out if you see it in
a shop
you have to call it out if you see
somebody discriminated against you have
to call it out you see in your workplace
you have to call it out every single
time and you don't stand for it
you know and you say you know taking the
knee is saying
we're not going to stand for racist
and racism you know in our society
that's what it means
and that's what it meant to all of those
players who did it on the pitch and
you know thank you to southgate for
making sure that he was firmly behind
that for wearing a rainbow
armband to say that we're not going to
stand for homophobia
either all of this matters if we are
going to build a society
for everybody and it's not about
tolerant nobody wants to be tolerated i
don't want to be tolerated i want to be
accepted it's about accepting people for
who they are
accepting their differences and not
judging people
because of the color of their skin or
because of their accent or because
you know of their inability or because
they're in a wheelchair it's about
accepting people
for who they are and that's how we build
a better society and that's how you be
that's how you that's how you become an
anti-racist
not by you know saying right okay today
i'm going to meet with
you know the social media providers
we've been calling for that for the last
two years constantly and you've done
nothing
and now the prime minister thinks he's
going to get a round of applause for
that
no chance let's see some proper action
dawn butler thank you
thank you
you